European fans are well they're they're
they're pretty Rowdy they are probably
the most Rowdy crowds I think in terms
of sporting events yeah uh yeah yeah the
worst tourists yeah we're the worst
tourists but we make for some of the
funnest sporting events I feel cuz like
in I don't know if I spoke on this on
the podcast when I went to watch I
watched I watched uh a very big game of
of uh basketball in la oh yeah I watched
uh it was like one of the a key game
between the two best teams at the time
the LA Lakers and Celtics I think I
think they're still the best teams yeah
very good teams I don't know but one
thing I found really weird is that they
don't chant themselves there's a there's
a speaker playing buildups to chant to
egg the crowd on to chant yeah oh
Japan's the same yeah because and like
it would keep like it would keep like in
like telling them hey hey chant defense
defense but it would I was my head I was
like this is so weird I'm sitting here
I'm like why why sced Che why do you
guys have to be cute this doesn't happen
in Europe everyone just go they just
start they just don't shut up yeah you
obnoxious yeah you go to local you go to
local matches and I don't know how
everyone in the stadium just knows every
chance that there is I think I think
they just figure it out it's not just a
chant either it's always like the ones
I've seen online is like one guy starts
the chant and then there's like a call
and response thing that happens and
everybody knows the words perfectly
knows exactly the timing of the class
those there's a few videos of guys who
start the chance it's really cool like
all right watch this starts chanting and
everyone joins in within like 30 seconds
it's really cool I remember I saw him
which just like just one dude just like
just holding the phone he like I'm going
to start the Chan just stands up and
he's like what do we think of blah blah
blah and everyone's like
[__] it's so fun that's like it's great
I love that [__] yeah it's good fun I I
really hope that you know we don't we
don't get rid of that in in all sports
yeah I I would like I would like to see
that translate to Esports cuz Esports
unfortunately bunch of [__] Gamers
with a lot of introverts you know we we
we like going to League of Legends
events and other Esports events they
know how to cheer right they know how to
like make noise but you know they don't
know how to [__] talk yeah yeah they
don't know how to [__] talk which I
think I I mean it's it's it's not
encouraged and it's also not encouraged
which I think is like a huge part like I
think like guys you can do it behind the
keyboard but not in real life well even
then they like don't do that uh I I
forgot what I was going to say I had a
point and I totally forgot it uh [__] me
okay I mean they're like League of
Legends is toxic enough online oh I was
going to say like but like Le has done a
fantastic job they have like they
literally have writers to craft the
narratives to to like basically you know
there's a lot of story lines happening
but they have to pick out stories and
like kind of sell the audience on them
uh and it's something they've been
really really successful with and really
good at uh well that's just normal
sporting yeah yeah but I feel like it
happens almost because of the way that
Esports is structured where there are a
bunch of people uh we don't see them
them physically uh we only see them on
the on the rift under a screen name we
don't really get like much of a
connection with the players yeah uh
other than like one or two very famous
players and because the rosters are to
always changing it's really hard to like
find like hear about players and know
what's happening yeah and so leag did
they've really done a really good job at
like kind of picking out these stories
humanizing the people and kind of
telling you the story as it goes and as
it's unfolding they they change it which
I think is really smart whereas in
football there's like a bazillion
commentators and and pundits and people
on the YouTube channels saying their
thoughts so there there isn't really a
need for narrative as much like
officially like they just people just
make up their own uh and that's pretty
successful doing that I think one of the
big advantages that the league Esports
has right now is one it's been like
going on for so long but two because
it's going been going on for so long now
that there are so many players in like
the kind of like League ecosystem that
have just been around for really really
long time we're getting there we're
getting there the I think League of
Legends on average is like uh much older
now uh and also is one of the oldest
Esports scenes in general like the
people who are in it are are generally
like late 20s now right on average I
think May which is crazy to say the
average age of League Esports I think
it's it's kind of cool I I mean I like
that I like that we're getting rid of
this notion that you have to be like a
certain like really really young that's
rocket League that yeah average age of
someone most League of Legends players
are between 21 and 20 oh no that's no
that's not
professionals uh go back go back I think
you had something though yeah you had
something before go back it rocket it
was rocket league but it also said
League rocket League 21 according to
Esports chart by I contrast the average
Asian League of Legends in CS 25 and 26
respect yeah which is a lot older just
cuz they're a lot they're we're already
too old to be yeah yeah yeah exactly
we're too we're too far gone God damn
well it's it's it's cool because like
you know that that means you have time
to emotionally invest yourself in some
of these bigger players uh I mean
obviously when we were there the most
famous League of Legends player of all
time was playing Faker and Sydney who
knows nothing about League of Legends at
all was just like oh why why is everyone
hyping up this Faker I don't [__] get
it like it's like sounds dumb sounds
[__] dumb and then she saw like Faker
pop off in like one of the games when he
was like Faker the goat one V4 and Cy
just turns to me and she goes I get
it and I was like yes that's what I'm
about Sydney yeah yeah but uh yeah it
was a lot of fun as well uh
unfortunately there is a downside to all
of this oh no what just just like the
sacrifice we had to make so after
watching League what do we do the first
thing we want to do is uh go to a this
is actually like the highlight of my
trip to Career actually this really fun
yeah we uh me Connor darus and Emily we
go to a PC Cafe and we just stay up till
3: 4 a.m. playing League of Legend
[__] awesome and oh my God I have I
cannot remember the last time I had so
much fun gaming like so good since you
can order noodles to your SE and the
noodles were so fire it was so godamn
good you can get coffees you can get
teas you can get drinks I'm not even mad
I'm just
disappointed so we we we had to get some
League Korean accounts which was kind of
hard to do we maned to get them and then
we we we were playing some games
together it was really fun yeah and it
it just reminded me like it just made me
realize how much I missed gaming when
you have your Bros next to you
physically oh dude land parties are
always the best like there is nothing
that compares to a land party yeah like
for sure yeah not the same otherwise it
just it was so reminiscent it brought me
back to like my University days where me
and the boys were just up till 3:00 a.m.
playing League some of the most fun I've
had in a very very long time and uh the
knock on effect they had was
unfortunately I was really wanting to
chase that high
again and
got back to Japan had a moment of
weakness and I was like this is like
watching a friend relapse on drugs like
and I was like maybe no maybe it's the
same maybe it's the same I had a lot of
fun playing League of Legends in Korea
loaded up uh my Japanese account and I
started playing League again and I just
I I finished like two games and I was
like I can't look myself in the mirror
again again I'm not your dad but I am
disappointing you like there was other
ways you know I think I would have just
preferred you to be a gacha gamer be
honest with you like I didn't realize
there was something better than a gacha
player but turns out there he is but uh
yeah I will say PC bangs in Korea they
[__] hit different they're so cheap
as well yeah I bet yeah we went to an
expensive one and it was like it was
like 10 10 bucks for 4 hours yeah that
was that was an expensive one that's
nothing yeah that like this was the like
high like the the high tier ones cuz we
went to the official SKT PC Bank T1 yeah
yeah SK T1 PC Bank and I didn't realize
this until uh I went like a second time
and I looked at the specs all the PC
there's uh all the PCS there had like
407s like graphics cards so they were
like the top high-end PC specs so of
course you expect like the uh you know
better Hardware as well but you can get
really really cheap PC bangs as well and
still have pretty decent gaming PCs to
go um and I went to one with Sydney and
uh went to one with Sydney I went to one
with Sydney cuz uh we were we were like
oh let's try playing Final Fantasy 14
again and I was just like oh my God
you're double dipping you're double this
is like this is like I went back onto
heroin and just I just decided to try
cocaine again as well you know just why
not I get it I just like playing in a
playing next to your Bros playing next
to your partner I get that aspect right
but you shouldn't be double dipping you
know leave leave some space in between
pick one I just wanted to see what the
experience would be like cuz I they say
pick your poison they don't say pick all
the poisons at the same time you know
that's what I did basically God damn it
um yeah I I kind of really really missed
that culture uh because I would I would
love to spend more time I think I would
PC game more if I could if there was
like more PC internet like PC bangs in
Japan no yeah totally cuz it's a totally
different vibe uh playing next to people
uh and just being in an environment this
is going to sound so sad being in an
environment where everyone's gaming
everyone's no it's definitely CH like
just see just seeing people just like
skipping lunch just ordering your
noodles and just like playing League
you're like oh I I want to be a
degenerate now I actually want to be a
degenerate the noodles are so good I
know what G's going to do when he goes
into
retirement H honestly like perfect
holiday Korea it's it's you know you
know K I'm sure it has like some we got
to go we got to go back just for a
weekend we we just game yeah me me me
and con want to go back and I'll
is just simply going to be just wake up
10: a.m. hit up the PC bang no life at
for like 6 hours or something go get
like a [__] amazing Korean dinner or
something like that come back play a bit
more games get like you know have some
drinks or something have some drinks and
uh sleep and then uh repeat for like two
days or three days or something you guys
are definitely G more Gamers than I am
that's for sure dude there's just this
it kind of like captured that uh I say I
joke I would be into it as well it's
kind of like capturing that that the the
summer break when you're like 14 you're
old enough to like really enjoy video
games now oh for sure and and you get
just days or hours on end to just waste
and play oh dude I remember when I was
like 14 13 and like I'd invite my
friends over during the summer holidays
and we'd we'd connect a bunch of PCS
together and do like a Civ 2 land party
all day like that was the [__] you want
to come with and play Final Fantasy 14
sh
play League of Legends with us come on
with the with the Bros God you know how
hard I've been trying to avoid playing
14 look look I'm telling you you're
going to like have one day of it and if
I go no that's the thing this is the
scary thing I don't want to say yes
because I know if I am in that position
especially with you boys and we're
playing 14 I am going to be hooked and
then I you will never see a video from
me ever again I'm not going to play 14
I'm playing 14 if that happens overly
I'm playing 14 I just like it's it it
reignited in me something I thought was
like dead which was the feeling of as
Conor said the summer break where you
just take a holiday which is like an
adult holiday where you you uh block a
bit of time off but instead of traveling
doing something exciting touching grass
you just uh just [__] no life this is
DJ this is DJ it's great that's fair
that's it's great um yeah that was
basically our Korean
experience literally the highlight of
the story kind kind of was I'm not I'm
not going to not saying that there are
not other things in Korea which were not
like great um you know I went shopping
I've much prefer Korean fashion but um
yeah my my my highlight was just playing
League of Legends and that it was very
fun that sounds so sad but it was so
much fun I swear to God I respect it oh
God whatever it was very fun got to do
it again all right I'm going to take a
piss break